alors en ce qu on se connaît bien tous
les cadres je vous ai souvent interviewé
je vous ai fait un petit peu toutes les
interviews que j'avais alors malgré tout
je suis arrivé quand même à récupérer a
récupéré quelques questions que je vous
avais jamais posée ça s'appelle les
questions jamais posé s'est bric et de
broc la cccd question que j'ai ramassé
un peu partout vous êtes contents de
notre voiture voulez je vous remercie
web bien claire chazal elle vous excite
bas maintenant plus philippe par exemple
du coup vous êtes pour l'entrée de la
turquie dans l'europe
je ne sais pas personne certes original
je n'en sais rien pour 18 parce que oui
salut mon ski sont conduites non il ya
70 millions + majorité musulmane ça fera
doucement 12è quelques courses on le
voit encore aujourd'hui quelle est ta
vision de la corse bien on continue
nous étudions au parc des princes
pourtant de la pelouse entre moi et
choqué plus en tant qu'acteur ou en tant
que chanteur monroe c'est kif kif
bourricot pareil
peu importe que vous dites quoi un peu
ça vous dirait de tourner une fiction
pour tf1
oui on rajoutera des rires montent à 2
par dieu je vais pas qu'il arrête
maintenant le bonheur
ah oui le kent gérard qu'est-ce que oui
vous aimeriez qu'on efface quel film de
votre filmographie teulé que j'ai fait
avec giovanni ça s'était très mal passé
les autres voilà ce que vous mais pour
vos pour la question plus personnelle
sinon aucun mais quand on les accepte on
les bat avec son coeur après vous avez
maigri et vous non comment j'ai maigri
oui y'a vous êtes vie sauvage et oui
vous pensez qu'on va encore devoir se
taper la canicule cet hiver pour cent de
toute façon à partir du moment où enfin
raffarin comme la canicule
il était bien évident qu'il n'allait pas
faire chaud oui je savais bien que cette
flambée du baril ça vous a fait pas trop
53 dollars au corps qu'est ce que ça
change au quotidien the star ironie fuel
de la culture chez de la robe en soie de
la roqia couette sympa à lire en ce
moment en son nom qu'est ce qui aurait
des saints pâlir en journaux vous car
tout cas à l'école à temps à bouger
ce match face à la question si non vous
n'êtes pas le poids mais là je suis prêt
ni en ce moment relation les jeux de
pouvoir ok ok d'accord ok ok ok ok donc
un collant ya la question suivante vous
la voulez si vous voulez oui comme c'est
à dire que cette cession est là celle-là
vous la voulez vous la voulez c'est la
question c'est pas comme ça que tu vas
voir
gérard millot non non non non je vais
vous la voulez oui ou non
première fois que j'ai rencontré il m'a
pas dit vous la voulez sinon il n'aurait
pas eu là ni vous avez écouté nouvel
album de sarnaut nom d'annie vous avez
côté le nouvel album de dany nom d'alli
vous pensez que ça à baisser
l'immobilier
non ça a demandé michel il vous manque
parfois je dois ça oui beaucoup
voilà la bonne question une belle
récompense est là c'était bien faire
parce que je sais pas exactement
michel il vous manque parfois joe dassin
oui beaucoup
avec michel aulas
leur mandat
chancy l'homme
jobs dans le cinéma
alors dany boon vous êtes à l'olympia
oui du 24 novembre 2 janvier oui je
pense que je vais faire un tabac ça se
présente bien ça ravi d'être à l'olympia
c'est une salle mythique d'anissa va
alors oui très bien donc nouvelle vie
nouvelle femme vacances sur un yacht 1
et puis cette patate toujours non
pourquoi je suis prêt à les suivre en
vacances sur un yacht à moi je les ai
vus dans voici sur un yacht un nom à
l'inversé un ponton ouais bah c'est joli
comme légende
dany boon faire ça pour ça pas pour la
fille donc l'olympia le 24 mai les
résultats tirés ardisson bonsoir soir la
6ème année septième année de la septième
année mais est ce que parfois vous
n'éprouvez pas des moments de lassitude
pas du tout non j'ai toujours la même
pâte a toujours la même patate qu'au
début oui on vous regarde tueries
continuent en boucherie armentières a
tiré sur en deuil mais la patate quand
même michèle laroque banque vous avez
tout votre premier film américain
ah oui aussi sais quoi est une amérique
alors j'ai acheté les droits de deux
livres un livre français qui s'appelait
pitcho j'avais déjà parlé caroline
bombance toujours en train de
j'essaie de développer et aussi j'ai
acheté un livre anglais qui s'appelle
les droits d'un livre qui s'appelle
don't let me in the night et c'est une
comédie romantique très sympathique et
ça que je voudrais faire là bas
voilà qui a redit sur mon soir et
pourquoi cette envie du prime time
toujours revenir au prime time savent
aussi fait pas cette émission si je
pense que ça me suffit alors pourquoi on
fait des prime time non mais pourquoi tu
fais des prime time je sais pas t'as pas
envie d'arrêter cette fois ci alors dis
le à la caméra vasiljevs bon coeur
dis-moi l'épreuve dames j'arrête mais on
arrête je souhaite c'est moins drôle
bien écouter l'info n'était pas parvenu
à armentières tirer je suis désolé pour
cette gamme est ce que est ce que
dominique segall est content catherine
sur le cd6 bien mais je crois qu'il
s'est pendu dans la loge qui arrive bien
gilbert bécaud je trouve ça bien alors
quatre civils à halo
dominique bonsoir bonsoir de minuit
bonsoir à volumique voulais savoir si
vous étiez content de la façon dont ils
ont vendu le film s'il avait oublié
quelque chose auquel cas nous pourrions
leur ajouter je ne vaux rien oui je ne
vaux rien il en a bien parlé gérard
invisible mois mais lui à la fin c'est
dany et moi j'étais plus sur le montant
des rançons munich segal bonsoir je vous
connais très peu en province est ce que
vous pouvez me présenter je suis canada
chez de prestige alors lui allait très
bien parlé du calme à la fin quand il a
repris la parole c'est ben oui parce
qu'il fallait dire au mont saint michel
dont on commence à trouver michel la
prestation de michel hamm et à non parce
que j'ai dormi avant de venir et les
personnes à la fayette tu vois alors
coup d'électrochocs bon je vous laisse
la matière si on va merci voyage
la bande originale du jeu